- WELCOME TO…
- [Audience:] “Which Teams Are Good?”
- Today’s guests are from the only teams we know are good:
The Patriots.
- You told me this was an indoor lacrosse game.
- The Ravens.
- I will destroy this game and redefine it in my image.
- And the Niners.
- [Audience member:] It should be the Seahawks.
- Please welcome your host, KIRK COUSINS!
- Bad.
- I think good?
- There can only be one purple team.
- Guys, the game hasn’t even started yet.
First up, ARE THE EAGLES GOOD?
- No, but they will win the division.
- CORRECT.
- Is, is this all you needed us for?
- NEXT UP: ARE THE STEELERS GOOD?
- Myles Garrett messed with their heads, but I will mess with their minds.
- Yikes, OK the RAMS.
- No, I think?
- The correct answer is, “We don’t think so, but it feels weird to say out loud.”
OK...LIGHTNING ROUND!
RAIDERS.
- Yeah, maybe.
- Hell yeah, man.
- COWBOYS.
- No.
- TEXANS.
- HA HA.
- You’ve won this battle, but I will win the war.
- And Lamar wins! Stay tuned for our next game show: “THE NFL’S KAP WORKOUT.”
- WE PLANNED THIS IN A DAY.
- Alright, listen up men.
Sometimes you hit the subscribe button,
and sometimes the subscribe button, it hits you.
But the important thing is to smash that like button in your dream.
- [Producer:] Alright Kirk, that's, we're good—
- THE ONLY COMMENT SECTION THAT YOU SHOULD CARE ABOUT IS
THE ONE INSIDE YOUR HEART.